al final del día, creo que
probablemente se deba a mi raza, ya sabes, y
me veo un poco más oscuro
cuando salí de allí y la gente se queda
allí me llaman soy amigo, así que
me veo un poco  Mexicano pero estaba en mi
ciudad natal
me apartaste mr.  Hogan, ven conmigo
, creemos que estás contrabandeando
narcóticos,
por lo que, siendo un artista, probablemente
no deberías poder permitirte ir a un
resort de cuatro estrellas e ir de vacaciones en
esta época del
año.
bajo la Aduana  Ley, se les otorgan
poderes muy amplios para buscar cualquier cosa y confiscar
cualquier cosa, siempre que haya motivos razonables
para que lo hagan, por lo que esa es
la clave.
Recientemente, el gobierno
federal anunció que
instituirán una agencia de vigilancia para supervisar
CBSA.